Barbie fans clutch their pearls cuz
Oscar ignored the girls and Hillary
returns from the Shelf to make it all
about herself the Oscar snubbed a Barbie
star Margo Robbie in the best actress
category and Greta Gerwig for best
director when nominations came out this
week but don't worry to ease all those
hurt feelings they already cried into a
bag of
money however Ryan Gosling who plays Ken
was nominated for best supporting actor
but even he wasn't happy saying quote
there is no Ken without Barbie to say
that I'm disappointed that they are not
nominated would be an
understatement which is the kind of
comment you'd expect from a man with no
genitalia saw that one yeah we didn't
even have to blur
it but critics are slamming him calling
his words blatant virtue signaling
speaking of women who don't win Hillary
Clinton took time off from luring
children into her gingerbread
house it's a chime in quote gret and
Margot while it can sting to win the box
office but not take home the gold your
millions of fans love you you're both so
much more than Ken hash Hillary
Barbie wow you know if I were Ryan
Gosling I'd let the world know I have no
plans to kill myself
it's because she's she stages
suicides but really do the Oscars even
matter anymore they're not even the big
event they once were especially with
Jimmy Kimmel hosting again a reminder to
Jimmy the event is Black Tie not
blackface good point
but but here's the problem with the
Oscars none of the subject matter
resonates it's like Hollywood misses the
real stories that affect real people in
a perfect world these these would be the
Oscar nominated fli like teacher
Transformer yes a heart-wrenching film
about a Canadian Woodshop teacher who
changes his students lives one massive
boob at a
time or Captain
Underpants a superhero movie for today a
potbellied rough around the edges
Italian biker Who video bombs TV spots
of an eccentric political pundit and
wins the hearts of Americans
everywhere and my favorite daddy
divorce oh my
goodness oh my
goodness Department make that like it
was yeah they they actually did that and
it will be the good news is it'll be
starring you Jamie in the title role and
you'll be playing yourself you know
what's funny when I looked at that
graphic I was like I don't remember the
last time I looked that sad and then I
remember it was just
[Laughter]
now the last segment have you been
thinking about uh this story and how
much it's affected your life the fact
that uh Barbie the actress whatever her
name was yeah Robbie wasn't nominated
has it affected you well I know a lot
about this my ex-wife actually won best
nonsupportive role in a marriage
[Applause]
um I don't like this story I don't like
Rich successful people complaining about
things that don't matter and I also
think Ryan one cuz he was best support
actor which is it's just an easier
category it's it's like going into that
category makes it easier to win in my in
my understanding and um I don't know I I
don't watch these award shows I always
felt like if I ever really did win
something they you know I just don't
know what I'd say because they always go
like oh I want to thank that my wife is
I was just like what would I'd be like I
did it even though you tried to stop me
uh in spite of you yeah the no thanks
you'd be doing no thanks yeah no thanks
to my kids who won't return turn my
calls yes no thanks to my divorce
attorney who let me get cleaned out yeah
I'd be like thanks to does anybody want
me to say their
name anybody thanks to
[Laughter]
Tyrus cat how sexist is it that Margot
Robbie wasn't nominated and instead they
nominated another woman in her
place that's pretty
sexist yeah okay so I'm going to do
something that I rarely do on the show
which is defend a
man I think Ryan goling okay what was he
supposed to do he had to he first of all
he doesn't get to be excited now because
it worked out this way and he had to
release a statement like that cuz what
what else would he do he'd be like hell
yeah like suck it like you can't
he
had so I I I really don't like people
criticizing him for doing this because
it was probably already written for him
before he even saw that it happened he
really had absolutely no choice and
Hillary Clinton she has never taken off
as a feminist icon the way that she
keeps trying to be because like you
can't be this independent woman feminist
icon like you're married to Bill Clinton
it just doesn't work and you trashed all
the women he slept yes
exactly well in my yeah team Lewinsky
for sure exactly Team all the women he
slept with that's a big team Tyrus and
they're all real women there's no men in
that team and if there is that's okay it
is
okay Bill would do it he'd be like okay
just turn around play the saxophone he
can do anything right yeah listen I I
Jamie first of all thank you for your
service yes bringing so much joy to so
many lives
um you know Robert Downey Jr maybe he
should go on X tonight and complain or
maybe somebody from Jurassic Park Barbie
is is a national icon making the Barbie
movie it did phenomenal it did great
little girls loved it little boys loved
it my kids loved
it and when you're a part of something
that is already in
itself a its own Enterprise playing a
character in that movie does not
necessarily mean that you're going to
get nominated you should be excited that
one of your cast members was nominated
given they're doing a doll movie
mhm that's like everybody who watched
Star Wars and be like why why didn't
Luke get because the the academy doesn't
put much weight on action movies and and
money-making movies that are designed to
get people to do what buy more Barbies
that was the point of the movie and they
accomplished it Jurassic Park
everybody's kid wants to buy a dinosaur
so I mean they accomplished that but
then we live in this time now where the
the this this if you don't nominate me
everything's bad and it's like a spoil
child they're AC like spoiled breast you
didn't get nominated but you are up for
eight others so be happy for the guys
that that were nominated for something
because there's a lot of movies that
weren't about dolls M that are that are
actually that were movies that are about
different things and they got nominated
and you didn't so instead you're like oh
this is and Hillary she just wants one
person and I nominate shaloo to say
Hillary we like you yeah just we like
you thank you you're good you may go
home now rest exactly she always has it
about climb in the coffin and just call
it a day Tom a related topic how is your
remake of Birth of a Nation
coming
oh I'm not that oldfashioned Greg I am
old fashion though I I come from a day
Greg when you made the movie and then
you made the doll you make the doll
second you don't start with the doll and
then make the movie great Point uh
Hillary Clinton she went even further
than that quote she he
compared uh the Barbie uh getting the
most money but getting snubbed at the
Oscars to her getting the popular vote
but not winning the presidency and if
anything the analogy should be flipped
around because winning the popular vote
is like getting the participation Trophy
and winning the presidency is like
getting all the money so you were right
that's the prize they already got their
money and it's probably not a very good
movie I get nauseous when I look at
stills from the movie because it's so
pink looks like a a Pepto Bismol
commercial to me it is something about
it's not for
you I loved it but I know everyone had
to pretend they liked it though and then
you have all these people you know the
stupid ones were the right-wing guys who
went to see it and then gave it a bad
review and it's like how about you just
stay home yeah no that's you know what
that is a great point because listen I
didn't care for my kids loved it I went
to it twice fell asly both times because
Mike no M you going to tell me not take
my daughter to movie BR your ass up here
I'll go we'll go to the Barbie movie
together and I'll make you sit on my
lap I didn't care for the movie my kids
loved it when came out on iTunes Daddy
can I have it of course you can because
my kids like it yeah it won it got
nominated for eight Awards how
victimology can these people be yeah I
don't know I love the movie I even uh
dressed up for it
w anyway all right up next he played
some tunes and got threatened by commi
Goons oh